[Music]
searching is a 2018 technological
thriller starring John Chow the film
follows the character David Kim as he
searches for his missing daughter
possessing a huge reveal the movie has
an ending with a lot to unpack and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
searching in full detail there will be
heavy spoilers so it may be worth
skipping this video for now if you want
to go in with fresh eyes without the way
I'm definition and this is my ending
explained video for searching after
losing his wife to cancer David Kim has
become a highly possessive single parent
the constant worry of his daughter isn't
helped by the fact that she goes missing
without a trace seeking aid from the
police does little to quell his anxiety
when it is decided by detective Vic who
has been assigned to the case that she
is likely just a runaway throughout the
film we follow David as he investigates
the disappearance and the movie becomes
the keyboard warriors version of take
David discovers that his daughter
Margo too was highly affected by the
death of her mother and this has turned
her into a loner which adds weight to
the fact that she may have fled on her
own of court red herrings are thrown in
such as a fake ID and misleading camera
footage but David doesn't give up the
search pushing himself to the limit
David tracks Margo to a lake where he
discovers her wrecked car submerged in
the water
believing she is dead David holds a
memorial but then his suspicions arise
once more when one of the screen names
he linked to his daughter returns by the
end of the movie we learn that it has in
fact been detective Vic who has been at
the center of the disappearance of Margo
and she has enacted this plan in order
to provide cover for her son who is
revealed to be the kidnapper Vic's son
was a close friend of David's daughter
growing up and through his knowledge of
her he has concocted a catfish character
that she has confided in similar to the
stories that we see with Nev and Max on
MTV Vic had lied about family illness in
order to extort money out of Margo but
the feeling guilty decided to come
luring her to the lake Vic revealed
himself to Margo which had a negative
outcome panicking at the scene Vic
attack Margo and with the help of his
mother attempted to murder her the two
covered up this attack and tried to hide
it from David as much as possible but
due to his persistence he managed to
uncover it and we learn that Margo
survived the ordeal personally I think
the film does a fantastic job of
displaying the possessiveness that
people gain after facing loss both
parents in the movie attempt to do
everything within their power to protect
and look after their child and this
leads to the extremes of their
personalities coming to the forefront
David is willing to go above and beyond
to seek out his daughter much in the
same way that detective Beck is willing
to participate in heinous crimes to
protect her son this shows how loss
leads to a greater love and appreciation
of what we have but on the flip side
showcases that it can have effects on
the ones we are trying to protect both
Margo and Vic are highly messed-up
individuals psychologically probably due
to the fact that they have never really
had to be accountable for their actions
due to the way that their parents
protect them to me this creates highly
complex characters and I completely
agree with all the high praise that
searching is currently getting it's a
film like no other that takes a unique
perspective on disappearances and I
highly recommend that you go and see it
so what did you think of searching did
you figure out the mystery and what did
you take from the characters
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and subscribe to my channel I create
content like this weekly and they'll
definitely be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of film recently I
discussed the post-credits scene of
sharp objects so make sure you check
that video out next linked at the end of
this one thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care of peace
[Music]